emile zola à tout au long de sa carrière
pas la société de son temps est décrit
en journalistes qu'ils étaient les
souffrances de l'époque
cent ans après la vie dans les
bidonvilles et le problème de
l'intégration réussie aura pu inspirer
zola je vous propose avec la sortie
mercredi prochain du gone du chaâba une
émouvante comédie sur l'intégration un
gone c'est en argot lyonnais un gamin
est précisément le film retrace le
parcours d'un enfant né dans un
bidonville français dans les années 60
c'était fanou mans frédéric basket comme
appel au marché le son enfance omar l'a
passée dans un bidonville comme il en
existait plusieurs aux portes de paris
lyon marseille dans les années 60
chronique chaleureuse d'une digue
provisoire le bidonville avait même un
nom les enfants d'aujourd'hui découvre
au cinéma ce passé oublié
dans ma ville je suis ici les parents
ils sont pas nés ici et tu leur a jamais
demandé pourquoi ils sont venus comment
ça s'est passé
est ce que ce film ça t'a donné envie de
parler tout ça était par endroits tout
pourquoi
franchement leur histoire qu'est ce
qu'on fait ici
le déguisement est le titre le
déguisement
vous allez à la ligne ce joli film est
aussi l'histoire vraie d'une intégration
réussie grâce à l'école aux instituteurs
et à la langue française d'un vieux
chapeau chapo le petit omar sy lui
azouz begag chercheur au cnrs qui a
raconté son enfance
d'abord mon père on me montrant ses
mains de maçon nous avons agi que ça
pour travailler je suis un manoeuvre
fait disait toi pour réussir dans la vie
il faut utiliser ça aussi c'est l'école
qui donne ça l'intelligence la culture
et m'a dit à l'école je veux que tu sois
premier de la classe devant les français
ça ça me ferait plaisir
cavaillé lyrique il et quand je leur ai
marre des précis quand ce sera trop dur
je fermerai le lieu je me mettrai à
courir vers les étoiles
ce premier film de christophe ruggia
adopte le point de vue des enfants comme
une guerre des boutons qui nous
parlerait d'aujourd'hui
à
ah ah